you just landed in a helicopter outside
here that's very impressive
you wanna make me look like a rock star
I think he's the rock star man the
washing machine story was amazing I
loved it you are really crazy
even in the best after-hours we don't
see people like you
you see if you should be a world star
you have to shows your own sport I do
show base in statistics I'm the only one
I become well when one stars like
Rihanna and Black Eyed Peas
they they need something special they
tend to call you they they they seem
self dependent on this touch you've got
boy what is it gets a touch please try
to explain it well maybe I should
explain what a producer is because a lot
of people they don't really know what it
is so basically you have singers and
some of the singers that write their own
lyrics but other ones you know you need
to you know bring a song like the music
choosing the right sounds mixing the
record helping them to get the best out
of them and that that's what I do I'm a
producer and a DJ also I'm actually
first of all I'm a DJ you come from from
yes
I start as a DJ and I started to make
beats to make the people dance and then
I started to want to give something more
more emotional and that comes with the
vocals and the songs and and this is how
I started to work with all those big
American you know urban stars because
they wanted to also to hear the music in
the clubs and make the people dance and
then we created something together with
Black Eyed Peas and a con and and Kelly
Rowland you know on my previous album
that really kind of changed we created a
new form of pop music really that is
working in the clubs but also on the
radio and it's exciting and it all
started back in your basement when you
were I mean you were like 14 years old
in France yes I was a yeah yeah I was a
bedroom DJ actually it's funny because
you know now you know people see like me
playing stadiums and stuff like this and
I really remember like all those years
playing to a wall on my own you're right
imagining one day I will have people in
front of me you know and it happened
when you when you're standing there
playing you know music on the stage and
you have like hundreds or thousands
dancing in front of you you have quite a
lot of power you can see this way that
wasn't a question you have yes but are
you able to manipulate the crowd there
was this show in Belgium it's called
Tomorrowland and I think it was so crazy
there was 40,000 people in front of me
and I started to move a little bit like
this you know and I see that hundreds of
people were moving like this you know
I'm at Wow I'm gonna push it and I'm
like so I'm starting to do it more and
more and and and I say I take the mic
you know and every I'm like everybody to
left and 40,000 people right to the left
to the right oh my god cuz you were
saying this and then I'm like okay
everybody sit down
everybody's saying that I'm like they
really do everything but kindness to me
is a little scary it's not a power thing
it's like I'm coming to party with the
people I'm coming to have fun with them
because I do this because I love it you
know I you know it's actually crazy that
they're paying me to do this because I
would do it for free
okay what would you do that
if you were to create this special
atmosphere with the five of us look at
look at look at us I mean what would be
the song which song would you choose I
have to make a special beat because this
is I see that you you especially him
yeah we have to make the washing machine
record together to honor my grandma yes
you never don't know no that's when I'm
vulnerable sometimes you know that was
once I had to dance that was after that
study in Cuba we had the big Congress
with all the neurologists in Cuba and
Cuban people work hard but then they
danced and I had to dance I was tough
so they had their I had drunk I was that
when you is your wife and you know I was
without my wife okay yeah so I was there
I was dancing and they started to look
happy they started to talk and looking
at me why I'm dancing well you know what
they were doing they were betting what
neurological disease I had
I'm retired you must have seen some bad
dancing of course I've seen some bad
dancing of course but it doesn't really
matter to be honest you know it's just
if if people are happy and they express
themselves I'm happy too you know are
you a dancer I am actually I really love
dancing what will be your home let's see
which is it I have my peak in the 80s
okay so I kind of look like to go back
there but I did recognize all the songs
they played and I do like that Kelly
Rowland one you have it thank you
definitely get me out Finn Jake thank
you just pay for a lot of people I'm so
excited but how many do you know so it's
I'm gonna play to two million people and
yeah it's crazy so uneasy there's four
million people going to keep a Cabana
Beach and the old dance to you know
local music and for the first time
there's gonna be a electronic DJ playing
and I'm gonna play for two million of
the four million which is already pretty
good yeah you should all come because
this is gonna be the party of the year
we have a very special musical act here
tonight and you had nothing to do with
it
it's Florence on the machine you know
them love this music
I think she will be very happy to hear
that
you